Hình khách một số công chính lịch sử dụng sốt đổ só chận động lất bẩy vầy đổ sẻ ra ở Myanmar hôm 2018.
Chua ma ha mua đi ở Manda Lai bất ngờ đổ sập, nhưng we zân thảo trải khỏi công chính.
Nguồ chua này là một trong những điểm đến lỗi tiến linh thiên ở Myanmar.
Chua ma ha mua đi được sĩ dựng năm 1 yên bẩy trăm tảm ý tư, có tự phật ma ha mua đi cao bún mết được sớt hàng tấn vạng.
Tù viện ma suyên năm 2014, cách công định mang đài lại khoảng 2 kí lúc mấy vị phiếu tới năm 2020.
Hãy tìm thải nào. Hát đồng hồ tại Tù viện này xúc đổ hoàn toàn.
Đây là một trong những Tù viện lớn và có anh rượn nhất trong cuộc vực, nơi tù học của hàng nghiên nhà sư và là chúng tâm nghiên cứu phật sáo quan trọng của Myanmar.
Chận động đất khủng tìm thải nghiêm trọng trong một Tù viện phật sáo ở Pinedaia, thuộc ma sàn của Myanmar,
cách tâm trận khoảng 1,8 kí lúc mấy. Như bảo tháp có nên đại hàng thiết kỳ tại khu dịch tốt sáo này đã bị đổ sập.
Kây cầu Ava được sĩ dự khoảng 548 mưu, mắc qua sông i ra Washington, lối liền các khủng manda lại và sáo gãi cũng bị sập sáo trận động đất.
Một phần của công định mang đài lại được sử đã bị hương hãi nghiêm trọng, tương sáo bao quan cung định thành đống đổ nát.
Cung định mang đài lại toạ lạc tại chúng tâm thành phố manda lại, là công định khoảng gia của cuộc miên mà được sĩ dựng vào 515 mấy bẩy giới chiều đại vô mình đến.
Chính quyền quân sự miên mà hiện bản bố tình trạng hình cấp tại sáo vùng, ý nhất sáo trong chimê tư người đã thiết mạng và gần 1 miên bẩy giâm người bị tương sáo trận động đất bẩy phẩy bẩy độ ở vình chung nước này.